well
hello how are you greetings sal y jaramillo
with your brief informative for today monday
september 20 last night a vigil was held
on behalf of the man shot and
killed in an apartment complex
west of the valley this happened near
jones and lightning on saturday
authorities said boy and the
world is 32 he went to visit his
sister when he was shot during an
altercation with three other people who
did not survive their injuries and died it is
unknown at this time if the police
have any suspects in custody if
you have more  information please
contact the authorities
a recycling warehouse located in the
center of the valley suffered a fire this
happened near washington and maine
around seven thirty at
night the fire department and
rescuers said that there were no other
properties affected due to
luckily no one was hurt in this incident
investigators are still trying
to identify what was ex  Actually
what started the fire and destroyed the
manchester march they believe it would have
started near the food court this
incident engaged almost 50
firefighters on friday this news is still
under investigation
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have a sunny day and with  winds
the maximum will be around 90 degrees
for today we will continue with these
temperatures for tomorrow we will
approach 100 degrees for the first day of
autumn beautiful days sal and jaramillo greet you
and this was your brief
informative edition in Spanish